you've watched a cut of skeleton Twitter
are you able to look at yourself and
look via little detached from it and see
yourself oh no you know all I see I see
is a Fred Armisen impersonation of me I
tell you Fred Fred Armisen to
personation of me is like this and then
I'm always just getting into some hugely
popular band do you always guys I'm
saying I just start listening to Bruce
Springsteen we all do impersonations of
each other dude you like Fred I do Fred
yeah Fred talks to his hands and he just
talks about Portland all the time I love
Portland I fly over there I have my
apartment and then Kristen twigs always
cold and always cold and then she's like
are you going to that thing are you
gonna go to that thing are you gonna go
to that thing that's what she is
she's cold oh he's always cold like
she's a giant space heater with her just
going around Jason Sudeikis is always
chewing gum all right buddy all right on
he sent me a very sweet text after he
saw skeleton twins it was so so sweet
long text about how much you loved the
movie and everything and and but I could
not not read it without thinking of him
chewing gum you go buddy
great performance love that buddy Olivia
and I loved it picture him giving giving
him trying to get a moving eulogy yeah
yeah wonderful guy
nobody died
[Laughter]
my beautiful dude
you know it's funny you're it's so good
at doing voices it makes me wonder I
know you your family is this something
it's familial do you have it in your
family do people do voices
yeah well my my wife said that when she
ate dinner with my family for the first
time that we all just do voices we all
we all do voices yeah not like oh and
she was like no no we just when we tell
a story we don't say oh I ran into
George at the store it's kind of more
like yeah we ran in and there there was
George he's at the store over there door
hey George is an idiot by the way people
people all do they just go into the
voice on a man yeah everybody my mom my
dad my grandparents we all just kind of
do boys there at home right now I'm
going oh look at Billy he's on Conan
[Applause]
[Laughter]
you